This space race.
Our next guest has been at the very forefront
Pam Melroy is deputy administrator of nasa
and a former astronauts, one of only two women
to come on to space shuttle also, she's a
former military combat the pilot, and she's
logged more than 38 days in space the us made
more than 100 space launches last year, more
than China, more than Russia.
But its moon missions have had a string of
setbacks and delays.
I asked Melroy where this leaves the united
States when she joined me from nasa hq in
Washington Pam Melroy, welcome to the program
>> Thank you.
Christiane, I'm a fan and I'm looking forward
to our conversation.
>> Thank you.
Well, I'm a huge space fan.
I to watch the moon walk Apollo.
Apollo 11.
Can I just ask you this though?
All we in another space race for 50 years
it's the United States dominated.
And now with the
[11:37:58 AM]
dominated.
And now with the private enterprise coming
into the space, travel, the space exploration,
we saw just recently a very hyped space space
X starships blowing up after takeoff in the
us last year, nasa was hoping that these would
really be, you know, some pioneering voyages.
We see that.
And then we heard the announcement that the
artemis mission to orbit the moon is going
to be delayed and then next, artemis mission
to land on the moon for the first time in
decades, is going to be further delayed.
At the same time countries like India, China,
Japan, or having national celebrations about
their successes.
Does this worry you
>> Oh, not in the least.
We have plenty of our own successes.
And I think that's evidenced really we have
the only vehicle that is currently capable
of taking huge women's to deep space.
We're the only ones who have that capacity
[11:38:59 AM]
ones who have that capacity today.
So that's huge.
Whatever you hope to do if you don't have
that, it takes a long time to develop that
capability.
Really, I think we look at this a little bit
differently.
Apollo was about taking a man to the moon
and returning him safely to Earth.
And that was the end.
We're doing something very different with
artemis.
We are trying to build a blueprint for responsible,
sustained human exploration of the solar system,
which means we need to take our time we need
to pay attention to safety, and we also need
to be thinking about doing much harder things,
which is sustaining a human presence in deep
space.
This is not about a camping trip, this is
actually about pushing humanity into the solar
system.
We've learned from the space station how hard
it is to sustain people in base.
It's a huge logistical problem.
So from our standpoint, we feel like we have
all the pieces in place to
[11:39:59 AM]
have all the pieces in place to go forward
we're going to do it methodically.
We're going to do it safely and we're going
to do it for the benefit of humanity.
>> Are you concerned that space space could
be more weaponized?
It could be yet another platform for more
I would say that nasa is both concerned, but
also determined not to let those things happen.
And that's why we're building an international
coalition to go with us, especially as we
push humanity out into deep space.
For responsible sustained human presence throughout
the solar her system.
>> Okay, so break some news for us here.
How realistic is it?
Do you think would you dream of finding life
outside and off?
Our plan is let me let me just quote a couple
of astronauts, Tim peak recently on CNBC says
the James Webb telescope may have already
found alien life.
We found a planet that seems to be giving
off strong signals of biological life.
>> Well, I personally think it's inevitable.
One of the things that's really been transformative
in planetary
[11:41:00 AM]
transformative in planetary science over the
last two or three decades, is realizing that
water, which is a critical building block
of life, is much more present even in our
solar system than we ever for imagined.
We thought asteroids were dry bodies that
had absolutely no water.
We had real questions even about the moon.
Now, we're finding it in places we didn't
expect seeing those building blocks.
And then our recent sample return from the
asteroid bennu shows not just water but carbon,
which is another critical building block of
life.
So I think it's only a matter of time.
I love the fact that we're finding biosignatures
potentially through James Webb space telescope.
But they're real benefit and the payoff is
going to be when we go to Mars and see if
we can find sigf life on our neighbor.
>> When will that be?
>> Well, I think it's hard to know on the
frankly, what you
[11:42:02 AM]
know on the frankly, what you don't know yet.
So we do know that it is our most interesting
neighbor with the highest potential to fall
find signs of life.
So as far as human presence goes, we're really
trying to set up a blueprint and we're going
to practice it on the moon.
But I'd like to see us head to Mars, I think
with our plan by the early 2040s, now when
you talked about Apollo, you said his mission
was to send a man to the moon and bring him
back safely that was not lost on me.
Are you there has been no woman walking on
the moon.
And I wonder what you thought, what is your
journey to the stars, so to speak, what inspired
you as a young girl?
>> Well, I was totally inspired by the Apollo
program.
And what's interesting is, as I have progressed
through my career, the number of scientists,
pilots, engineers that I've met who were also
inspired by the Apollo program
[11:43:04 AM]
>> For man so, what is exciting to me is to
see that
>> Our artemis campaign, I believe is going
to unleash a tidal wave of young people interested
in stem and in space exploration.
And this time it's going to happen all around
in the world.
And I'm pretty excited about that.
>> And how did you get into this business
>> Well, back in the day, the only astronauts
that I knew about where military jet test
pilots.
So being a little stubborn, I decided that's
what I was going to do to even though women
were not actually allowed to fly yet, in the
military but I was very fortunate.
I was born exactly at the right time.
I think Christiane, I feel very fortunate
that the doors open just just ahead of me
allowing women to fly jets in the air force,
allowing me to become a test pilot and that
was my progression to becoming an
[11:44:06 AM]
progression to becoming an astronaut.
>> Best pilot, it sounds so cool and dangerous
and scary and top gunny and phon and